you came out a while ago with a book of
photographs it's called photograph it's
what's interesting is whenever you see
pictures of the Beatles in all that
those crazy years you guys always have
cameras with you and you were all taking
pictures but we never got to see them
yeah and then we started seeing them in
the last 10-15 years and you released
your photographs and it's fascinating
about it is Beatle fans like myself got
to see what it was like from a Beatles
perspective show which was fence at like
here's a picture you guys are headed to
you're in you're headed to this is so
New York City just jump in here yeah
it's we've just landed in New York we're
heading for the hotel cops on motorbikes
you know who you huge motorcade 19 and
these kids had come to see us and they
just came alongside and just by chance I
thought I'm gonna take a shot of that
yeah and what was great when the book
you talking about came out last year
they found all those kids I want kids
anymore of course right and it was so
great you know that yep I had that image
I just got lucky
yeah and and then we found them and they
came to Vegas we're at the opening
that's fantastic yeah you took a shot I
don't know what this one is it's it's it
looks like Paul McCartney balls he's
become French yes he's become very
French and we were actually were in
France and whatever country we went to
he became that person and that's what's
really interesting it was really
interesting women to Denmark he just
became he became Danish and then I
absolutely love this one it's fantastic
yes that's great is that John that leg
that yes isn't this far out this is the
craziest picture I ever took this is how
John used to sit he would sit low I
can't do it and I work out and he's got
his foot up here so he was like
double-jointed why don't we have the
audience try that
you know you'd hear a lot of snapping
and cracking something I took I mean you
know that's how he sat and he's God in
that box of nothing but the any Scottish
glasses off so it was really one of
those moments you guys said we had
nothing else to do so we just
photographed each other
yeah that sounds kinky
you